for some an empty beer can goes into the
recycling bin for others it's washed out
and put on a shelf as art today we
celebrate the collectors because today
is National Beer Can appreciation day
and here tell us more is windy forest
with craft House brewery welcome back to
the show thank you thanks for having me
National Beer Can Appreciation Day what
is it all about uh well it should be
every day right all right let's do it
so we're just appreciating the art that
goes into putting our beautiful beer
inside these cans and why cans are the
chosen format that most craft breweries
are choosing to put their beer in now as
a kid I used to collect cans because I
thought they were so cool you never
Miller Lite and your your Coors Light
but any kind of stuff like this talk
about some of the beer cans we had in
front in front of us what makes them so
special sure
um so we use a local graphic artist
to produce all of our cans and she is
um really the voice of Las Vegas so we
like to reflect where we brew and we
like to have an artistic eye on those so
just like the label is a expression of
art so is the beer that's going inside
that can and these are also these are
all the beers that you guys serve yes so
hops well so this beer here they have
the beer first and then they design the
label how does that process work well no
we work together as a collaboration with
the Brewer with my husband and with our
graphic designer with you know what
story do we want to convey and you look
at each can each one does tell a story
it does and that's the amazing thing
about craft beer is we are storytellers
I'm going to hold this one up down here
because this one Rebel Spirit obviously
a nod to UNLV tell me about this beer
right here uh so we are the official
beer of UNLV are you really yeah so yeah
because I love it and we donate a
portion back of the proceeds to our alma
mater so we are all graduates of the
hospitality college and and what does
this beer taste like um it's a golden
ale so it has nice round notes not too
hoppy it's meant for tailgating you can
have quite a few and and still make the
game that is UNLV right there why
aluminum for beer cans
um well first and foremost it protects
the quality of our beer um our Brewer he
uh toils day and night of how he can
make the most quality product that he
can out there it reduces our carbon
footprint it's infinitely recyclable
um there's lots of great great sense
okay uh the bag oh my God yeah exactly
so wait we're like we got a bag a beer
bag tell me more about that about the
beer bag it's
fun for um especially pool season
if you want to go swimming you can have
your Koozie sling or if you want to go
to a beer festival then your hands are
still available you can sample it is a
beer bag everyone needs to have a beer
bag I thought it was your purse at first
like ask her about the beer bag like
what beer bag this is fantastic yeah
where are your locations in one downtown
I know that I see it all the time down
there so that one's in the arts district
or burrito right off of Maine in
California and then our Brewery where we
Brew with another Tap Room is Henderson
and that's in what we call the booze
District perfect okay out of these beers
which is your favorite that's like ask
me which is my favorite child I know
gotta pick one though it's always the
newest one so the newest one is actually
not a beer that's hop swell that's a
sparkling okay I want you to take one
because there's something very special
right here yes because Ted florendo our
weatherman yeah over there yes yesterday
was his birthday so Ted cheers for you
buddy guys I love you